you happen to have diabetes no I don't
at least I don't know if I do well I can
check up every year but not the diabetes
okay I don't feel like I got I never had
any problems in my house well have you
had a check-up written a year ago x-ray
and one of these mobile use
what is neither it when you don't have
enough for that chemical that dissolve
your blood it is all these sugar don't
have enough of that spit I can't think
of a right now it's a disease yeah I got
too much sugar you don't have
that's too much they're not enough it
sounds like that no we are too like
separated I don't think it's sugar here
blood sugar in your pancreas just you
know what diabetes is yeah what is it
well it's a simulation of sugar in the
system relateable well you're thirsty I
know and I believe loss of weight and
nervousness
[Music]
you never know I never had it well the
symptoms this year go into a coma you
can go into a calmer aura
yeah sugar in your urine have it in your
blood how would you know I don't know
many times I think I have it myself well
maybe she does have it anyone can get it
but three out of four diabetics are over
40 and overweight and the majority are
women all the people interviewed know
something about diabetes but none of
them had a very clear idea they were
aware that it has something to do with
too much sugar in the blood or in the
urine or somewhere before we go further
let me explain
diabetes is too much sugar in your blood
and some of this overflows into the
urine what cause is this not having
enough or the right amount of insulin
which comes from the pancreas how does
this affect you well let me introduce
you to some people who have diabetes mr.
Mudd who is a mechanic mrs. cook a club
woman mrs. jezik a grandmother
Kathy nikana a young girl mister Alta a
retired Baker and mrs. Levine a
housewife some are old and one at least
is quite young but whether old or young
diabetes hasn't dampened their spirits
this isn't surprising among those who
know they have diabetes for them it's a
matter of taking their treatment and
keeping the disease under control
it's the ones who have diabetes and
don't know it who are likely to be
dispirited in fact one of the early
signs of diabetes is having no energy
however there are more obvious symptoms
than that let's hear from the people you
just met and find out how they first
discovered they had diabetes and take
mrs. Levine for example
she has a family history of diabetes in
fact this is true of one out of every
three diabetics I've been told by the
doctors but the possibility of me
becoming bad that it was very strong of
my parents of diabetics and I remember
that most of my life mrs. Levine had an
early warning when routine tests during
her pregnancies indicated a tendency
toward diabetes but it wasn't until
sometime after her children were born
fine normal babies but rather big that
the three main symptom stressed
themselves upon her first excessive
urination and hunger the family tendency
to have diabetes asserted itself and
mrs. Levine was diagnosed as a diabetic
on the other hand some people have no
warning at all
with driving along and all of a sudden I
felt faint so I moved over to the cake I
blacked out I just got in crisis and I
have impacted a doctor I came to a
doctor examined me at first
mr. month had what appeared to be a
fainting spell
it wasn't until his second attacks that
the diagnosis was made but six months
later I and I all of a sudden I felt
dizzy I pulled a little quake and I
stood there for a minute or two couple
of minutes and I came back to it and he
sent me down to take blood tests and a
urine test and if I mother has diabetes
other symptoms of the disease are
infections that will not heal crops of
boiled itching and mrs. Jessica's case
it was boiled and thereafter I had about
30 boiled so I went to see the doctor
about it and the doctor sent me through
a padi allergist for a test and he
discovered that I had diabetes
not much but diabetes nevertheless
though most diabetics are middle
aged or older when they find they have
it this was not so with Kathy nikana
Kathy is one of quite a large family and
is the only diabetic among them she is
now 13 I've had diabetes for two years
since I was 11 I had a large infection
on my leg and my mother decided it was
it wasn't healing we should go to the
doctor and have him check it
she was also worried about symptoms I
had because I was urinating frequently
and drinking a lot of water the doctor
took a urine test and the slow healing
infection proved to be a symptom of
diabetes the same thing happened in mr.
Alcala case another accidental discovery
I was a second of Box down from the on
the rafts on that box slipped and hit me
right in the eye on that cut there right
here and it under Ibaka I'd have cut
their skin dinner was good gone to my
dark to see when he couldn't find out
first why did this annealed got cut see
and then he said there's something wrong
with you all right Denise took a test on
them he found sugar in my urine finally
there was mrs. cook who noticed no
symptoms and came very close to dying
before she found out she had diabetes
but let her tell you about it I went
into a serious state of shock nobody
would tell me what happened but I know
that it was serious because there were
about four nurses and I don't know
whatever about my bed and they started
intravenous and stomach I forget what
you call it but it's the stomach pump in
half and their intravenous feeding and I
know that they brought the priest into
me gave me the last right I was
conscious the moment the - and then I
fade out and but I was in that state for
three days
fortunately for mrs. cook she received
excellent medical care immediately had
she been alone when this happened she
might have died you have met six people
out of a million and a half Americans
who are under treatment for diabetes
known diabetics it is estimated that
another million and a half have diabetes
and don't know it these are the
diabetics unknown they range from the
mildly afflicted to have no other
symptoms and tiring easily to those who
have persistent signs of thirst
excessive urination and hunger
to those who will only find out that
they have diabetes by going into a coma
in which case they may not live to find
out just how these signs and symptoms
relate to what is happening inside the
human body it's something that you
should understand so we are going to
show you some animation in the normal
person sugar that has been eaten goes
from the intestine into the liver some
sugar is kept by the liver and the rest
makes its way into the bloodstream by
way of the heart some sugar enters the
muscle cells where it is burned at once
to provide energy some is converted into
fat and stored for later use what is
left over travels to the kidney and back
again into the blood system insulin is a
chemical produced by the islets of
Langerhans in the pancreas its function
is to make it possible for sugar to
penetrate the cells particularly the
muscle and fat cell in the normal person
the flow of insulin decreases if smaller
amounts of sugar are taken into the
system and increases with more sugar
just the right amount for the occasion
is fed into the blood system to enable
the sugar to enter the muscle liver and
fat valve the diabetic chemical problem
is that he does not have a natural flow
of insulin
it is either deficient or non-existent
since the sugar can't get into the cells
it remains in the bloodstream so the
diabetic has high blood sugar
since the blood reaching the kidney has
too much sugar some passes into the
earth so sugar in the urine is another
indication of diabetes the diabetic
drinks a great deal of water to enable
the kidneys to get rid of the excess
sugar this water passing through the
body rapidly results in frequent
urination without insulin the cells
cannot burn sugar for energy and so the
body begins to burn stored fat instead
similarly the fat cells cannot take in
more sugar to replenish their supplies
of fat as the store of body fat is used
up the diabetic yearns for more food
trying in vain to replenish the fat
cells instead he usually gets thinner
it's a vicious circle one great danger
of diabetes is that the burning of these
abnormal quantities of fat may produce
excess acidity in the body as the doses
which induces coma and even death this
is why until quite recently diabetes was
a terrifying word today except among
diabetics unknown acidosis rarely
occurred the remarkable discovery of
insulin in 1921 and the recent
development of new medicines that can be
taken in tablet form makes it possible
for diabetics to live normal happy lives
actually some diabetics keep the disease
under control without any medication
whatsoever however all diabetics have
this in common they must watch their
diet and take the right amount of
exercise in fact for the diabetic
medication diet and exercise are
interrelated keeping the balance between
these three is what every diabetic must
learn to do in the beginning it's hard
as Kathy's mother found out she was used
to eating her lunch at 11:00 we had been
shopping the excitement of her shopping
and trying on clothes
and so forth and it at 12 o'clock I
heard the whistle and I said you we
better get her her lunch as we went into
the ice-cream parlor
she said to me I don't feel well and she
was breaking out into a sweat which is
the fact that she didn't she had more
insulin and she had sugar so I
immediately asked for a glass of orange
juice at which they gave me very quickly
Kathy felt better right away like all
diabetics should she carries a card that
identifies her as a diabetic in case of
an emergency however now that she has
learned to balance her diet and insulin
against her activity there is little
likelihood that she will have any
trouble when she goes bowling or to
dances she knows she can eat more and
she does experience has shown her how to
adjust almost without thinking about it
they usually have cookies and I eat some
of them because I'm exercising dancing
it's up to the doctor to decide which if
any medication the patient should have
and how much of it with severe cases of
diabetes injections of insulin are
needed to move the sugar out of the
blood and into the muscle and fat though
where it belongs for others the new
pills may be taken to help the pancreas
secretin of insulin and many others it's
simply a matter of diet I was put on
[Applause]
insulin gradually increased till it came
to the right amount and urine test and
once in a while blood test I administer
the injections myself self-discipline is
a vital ingredient of treatment when it
comes to diabetes mrs. Levine is a good
example of the ideal patient as a
diabetic there are three things I have
to be concerned about that I take my
medicine daily then I watch my diet very
carefully and that I do my exercise
daily every few months mrs. Levine sees
her doctor he gives her a blood test
checks her weight and reviews her diet
chart mrs. Levine finds it's much easier
to handle the dietary
and then when her mother and father had
diabetes everything then had to be
weighed and measured I do most of my
shopping at the supermarket and I buy
very much what anybody else buys it
buy a lot of fruit at the food
department
mr. Ulta takes medicine and watches his
diet but nostalgically you know I used
to like noodles with a pancake mix
applesauce and all this stuff I could
eat that for breakfast you know in the
morning he cut that all out and put me
on a strict diet vegetable less black I
ate two slices blood in the morning for
for breakfast and then I eat I write the
grapefruit middle sugar they way they
come no sugar when are we Oh Neil I put
salt on there instead of sugar and then
I use only skim milk because the doctor
that time and they had the eczema nation
when he put me on them foods nor threat
nor water you cut me out of the bottle
and cut me out of the test mrs. cook
takes her medicine and stays on her diet
most of the time I need no injections
and I take two tablets a day and that's
really old all the inconvenience there
are time that perhaps I don't have quite
as much energy but generally that's
because I haven't lived up to the rule
mr. Mont is one of the diabetic who
needs neither insulin or pills
he keeps the balance entirely through
diet and his strenuous work provides
most of his daily exercise I am pea
levitated and recall the wedding this is
a small radiator but for so long
I write very big it's a very big
readiness you know you require some any
handling lifting up and all that
mr. month like most diabetics can hold a
full-time job in fact three out of four
diabetics are not restricted in any
daily activity the new medicine and
greater knowledge of the disease
made all this possible years have been
added to the diabetics life in fact some
diabetics are living much longer than a
great many other people who don't take
such good care of themselves but what
about the million and a half persons who
have diabetes and don't know it the
diabetics unknown why don't these people
know many do not recognize or do not
have the common symptoms of thirst
excessive urination incessant hunger
others don't want to face up to the fact
some find it out when they go to their
doctors for other complaints far too few
make the discovery in the best possible
way the annual medical check-up that
looks for any and all diseases mrs.
Cooke whom you will remember almost died
because she didn't know she had diabetes
has become an eloquent spokesman for
this I hope the times coming when people
will go for more people will go for
their annual checkup and let the checkup
include a testing for diabetes diabetics
are also found through screening
programs organized by voluntary health
associations with the help of the County
Medical Society and by local public
health department sometimes they are
held in local hospitals such a place is
the Middlesex Hospital in New Brunswick
New Jersey where mrs. Susan Ryan era
went for her tests mrs. Rheiner first
became interested in diabetes through
the American Diabetes Association she
read a pamphlet and discovered that
women of her age group were most likely
candidates for the disease
there was quite a group the morning she
went to the hospital and she stood in
line to register in the laboratory the
doctor took a sample of her blood the
technician prepared it for the automatic
machine that makes it possible to screen
many people quickly by handling 12
samples at a time or up to 1,000 a day
it takes five minutes for the processing
one test tube comes off the machine
every 30 seconds mrs. Rheiner waited for
her results the test tube dropped off
the rack
it was colourless this meant that mrs.
Rheiner was a suspicious case she was
referred to her doctor for a further
checkup and he in turn was notified of
the results mrs. Rheiner his doctor told
her that he would have to do more
definitive tests to find out whether she
actually had diabetes that this was
merely an indication however it would be
well to do these tests right away if
people could only know how much more
uncomfortable not to mention the danger
aspect it is to live with untreated
diabetes and it is to take care of it
I'm sure there would not be a
million-and-a-half undetected diabetics
in the country today if you need more
convincing on this point let's ask our
diabetics what difference it has made in
the way they live you know they say when
you have an incurable disease you live a
longer healthier life and it's very true
because your Venter think of everything
you do before you do it Kathy is an
honest student a high honor student in
the enriched course so in other words
she's in the eighth grade but doing
ninth grade work well the one thing that
was stressed was that you do not treat
the diabetic any differently we do not
treat Kathy any
differently but and of course Kathy is
of the nature that she wouldn't allow
herself to be treated any differently
anyway she has never felt sorry for
herself she has no reason to feel sorry
for herself I do a lot of work around
the house but we have to be done the end
hours I paint I shrug snow this winter
course snow shovel is not the Iowa
doctor tells you if you're over 65 and
I'm going on 72 you shouldn't show me so
much snow
note that it is mr. out house age and
not his diabetes that is the restriction
here mrs. jessic is more philosophical
well at first I was very unhappy but
then I realized it's a problem you have
to judge yourself once the pattern has
been established diabetes is not hard to
live with it's a lot of things in life
I'll get used to so I had to get used to
that too and so these people and the
other known diabetics throughout the
country are safe happy feel fine and
live long and useful lives two
generations ago diabetes was a threat to
life itself but not today the only real
threat is not finding out in time by
having annual checkups or ignoring the
hereditary factor and such common
symptoms as excessive thirst urination
hunger oil and the rest and becoming by
default a diabetic unknown do you happen
to have diabetes
anybody in your family well my husband I
could have slightly buddy disabled
Andrew for sudden so ending now he's
dead well I have a little I did have it
I did have diabetes a group or well I
went to Meadowbrook Hospital and I had
some insulation and I feel better now
didn't capacitate the person yeah are
they taking some in shots every day and
keep still alive like the rest of us
if they can't Karen in film alright
thank you very much I'm Joanne Whalley
state director of health education in
Maryland and also a representative of
the conference of state health educators
I am here to speak for you the audience
and I hope I'll ask some of the
questions for which you'd like the
answers here to discuss some of the
aspects of diabetes are three physicians
who are specialists in the field dr.
alter Krawczyk dr. Francis Lukens and
dr. Carrie Gunderson let's review the
usual symptoms of diabetes dr. Gunderson
the symptoms are fatigue weight loss
excessive thirst and urination hunger
cramps in the legs boils that won't heal
or wounds that won't heal statistics
show that diabetes is most likely to
occur to those who have relatives who
have the disease would you comment on
this hereditary factor doctor Lukens
diabetes is six to eight times as
frequent in the family of a diabetic as
it is in the general population we know
little about human heredity but this at
least gives us a practical guide in the
early detection of this condition if a
person has diabetes in his family and he
enjoys eating sweets should he stop
eating sweets the sweets only matter as
of the total food he eats he should keep
his weight right on whatever diet will
do this doctor crossing who is most
likely to have diabetes this Wally women
have a higher chance of developing
diabetes than men especially those who
have had several pregnancy overweight
may be one of the causative factors in
diabetes and we know that the most
common age is that between 40 and 70
when diabetes first appeared isn't it
true that an early sign of diabetes for
some people it's actually loss of weight
yes some diabetics have an enormous
appetite and eat huge quantities of food
and lose weight in spite of this one
thing that struck me about the film was
that mrs. cook and mr. Mont didn't seem
to have any symptoms of the disease
before it was diagnosed does this often
happen well Maya diabetics may have no
symptoms at all except fatigue this is
most likely to be true of those patients
who are detected by an annual checkup
examination I guess this means that the
only truly preventive measure that a
person can take is to have an annual
physical checkup
yes that's quite true it's a good idea
to see the doctor once a year maybe on
one's birthday and be checked up
completely with examination of urine and
blood and of course then you could also
check for other diseases at the same
time now sir Lucan isn't true that quite
a few County medical societies have
sponsored diabetes detection program yes
the Philadelphia County Medical Society
joined in testing 3,500 people last fall
dr. classic what are some of the testing
methods well we use urine tests and
blood examinations in New Jersey we find
that urine tests are rapid and
inexpensive the blood tests are much
more accurate in film detection programs
automatic analysis and techniques of
this type
we'll provide an answer in just a few
moments most of the people have to do
not have diabetes but those who are
affected are sent to their family
doctors for further tests you know
sometimes the person who is told he has
diabetes is very frightened yes that's
true
being a diabetic myself I can understand
this feeling however once I was told
about the disease and learned how to
take care of it the fear disappeared
I've taken instan myself now for 22
years and would rather take a shot than
shave since it takes less time and
effort and of course most diabetics
don't have to take insulin they can get
along quite well on pills or even on
diet alone doctor Lukens isn't it true
that diabetics should try to avoid cuts
and other injuries most diabetics get
over cuts very well the important
exception is injury to the feet
particularly in elderly people is there
a cure for diabetes no there is no cure
for diabetes but it can be completely
controlled just as the nearsighted
person can have normal vision with
glasses without actually curing the eyes
so the diabetic can lead a completely
normal and useful life if he takes care
of the condition some people believe
that diabetics don't have normal
children this is just an old wives tale
yes diabetics have normal children I
have four very normal ones myself
although it seems to add up to the
important point the diabetes isn't too
bad a disease to have that is if you
realize that you have it and you take
care of it properly
diabetes hasn't interfered with my life
to any appreciable extent I feel just as
normal as next person everyone should
know the symptoms of diabetes and should
have a test at least once a year no one
can feel that he is exempt from this
condition now you know something about
diabetes the usual symptoms and how to
find it early do you know whether or not
you have diabetes don't be like the
nervous medical
student who thinks he has each disease
you read about but be examined for
diabetes at least yearly if you are fair
fat for he or some lead with diabetes if
you are not in this ought to be tested
group this picture should make you join
in general detection programs and be a
better and be a better informed citizen
able to help someone who missed seeing
this film
[Applause]